I want to start with CPAC today the
conservative political action conference
holding their first 2023 event uh
starting Wednesday March 1st now I was
particularly interested in this CPAC
because it was going to allow us to see
what is going to be the approach of this
group
to the 2024 primary at this early stage
where Donald Trump is still in command
we have to admit but there is a
fracturing and there are different
elements of the right some of which like
the idea of more Trump and some of which
are decidedly anti-trump and then
organizations like Fox News were sort of
saying well we'd rather someone else but
we're not going to completely abandon
Trump we're going to wait and see what
would be the mood at CPAC because of all
of these different speakers giving us a
window into the talking points that
would be applied to the 2024 primary or
hypothetically
might the CPAC speakers just ignore the
2024 primary as if it's not going on
sort of ignoring it like an elephant in
the room that nobody wants to talk about
well we are still going to be able to
see but it is going to be with a much
diminished audience and fewer Republican
insiders and the background of all of
this is that a guy named Matt schlapp
who is not exactly a beacon of gay
rights has been credibly accused of
um uh uh what's the right word at
minimum sexual harassment and I believe
it is accurate to say sexual assault of
a male staffer some months ago and it is
believed that this is sort of the black
cloud over the head of CPAC so let's
look at a couple of different articles
explaining what's going on first and
foremost CPAC is being ignored by Fox
News
um one of the biggest outlets for CPAC
getting attention is that Fox News
covers the event interviews people there
promotes the event Etc Daily Beast
writes CPAC has a major Fox News problem
after right-wing power broker Matt
schlapp was accused of sexual assault he
and his annual confab have all but
disappeared from Fox News a shocking
break from years past and it is a break
for shocking you know is sort of
subjective but it is certainly a break
amid the alleged groping scandal
Justin baragona for The Daily Beast
rights over the past few years the
conservative cable giant has not only
aired the entire multi-day conference on
its Digital streaming platform Fox
Nation but the network has also been a
featuring sponsor in 2021 for example
Fox Nation paid a quarter of a million
dollars to help underwrite the overtly
partisan Gathering the year before that
they paid 28 thousand dollars to be a
sponsor as of publication schlapp and
his annual convention have all but
disappeared from the Fox News Universe
none of fox media's Outlets are listed
among their sponsors which includes
their conservative archrival news max as
well as far-right competitors like real
America's voice additionally Fox
staffers told The Daily Beast they have
yet to receive any guidance on how they
will cover CPAC an apparent Fox News
blackout on CPAC would present a
stunning break from past years which
reliably demonstrated a symbiosis
between the cable Giant and the right
wing confab Hannity and Laura Ingram
would often deliver speeches or host
panels which then the network carried
and then outside the ballroom you would
see Fox people walking around it's not
clear whether any of that will be going
on now the context does seem to be the
alleged groping Scandal that I I there
was some speculation that this break
between Fox News and CPAC has more to do
with Trump than it has to do with the
groping Scandal maybe but I've not seen
any actual evidence of that and The
Daily Beast article does mention The
Daily Beast first reported that schlapp
allegedly groped the crotch of a male
staffer
on failed Republican Senate candidate
Herschel Walker's campaign the
individual this is insane that these is
this is the language that's being used
claimed that Matt schlapp graphed his
quote junk and these terms are all in
quotes and pummeled it at length and it
was scarring and humiliating schlapp is
just denying he's like nah it didn't
happen even though there are text
messages that do seem to show
slap uncomfortable and and maybe I don't
want to say apologetic but regretful in
some way
um schlap is as far as we know uh
heterosexual and married to a woman so
that is part of the problem that CPAC is
having now there's another story with
this Mike Pence declines invitation
to CPAC as events leader comes Under
Fire this is from ABC News the decision
by Pence who is debating a 2024
presidential run writes ABC News comes
as other notable figures are absent Ron
DeSantis who spoke at CPAC last year has
two events in Texas as CPAC will be
underway in Maryland a spokesperson for
CPAC told ABC News neither Pence nor
DeSantis are currently slated to attend
uh DeSantis spokesperson didn't respond
and uh Pence didn't attend in 2022 and
declined to attend in 2021 the context
here is also believed to be the sexual
assault Scandal Trump is scheduled to
headline the event so I think that this
is actually normally CPAC is kind of a
waste and I don't typically cover much
of it if any sometimes we've not covered
any of it live
my goal this year was actually to cover
the major speeches Live on YouTube
twitch and Facebook again because of the
interest that I have
in seeing how CPAC frames the 2024
Republican primary now one of the things
that may happen by default is there are
with DeSantis and Pence as possible 2024
Republican candidates snubbing the event
and Trump going CPAC may just default to
will praise the hand that feeds us Trump
is coming here to speak so we will just
get behind Trump but we don't yet have
the full agenda I hope it will be
released soon and uh we will see what
the coverage is from Fox News we will
see what the attitude is towards the
primary I'm actually as interested as
I've ever been in uh covering a CPAC
which is not typically the case Ron
DeSantis who has not yet announced that
he is running in 2024
will not be at CPAC but he was
interviewed last night by Fox news's
Mark Levin now I we're going to look at
clips of the interview the interview was
completely deranged and delusional it's
not clear who's more deranged and
delusional is it Ron DeSantis or is it
the host Mark Levin but just for a
little bit of context Mark Levin has a
weekly show on Fox News and there's
always these story lines that develop in
media Outlets these sort of Cults of
Personality or story lines that are that
are used among different people the
storyline about Mark Levin is that he's
the more serious guy
he is a legal scholar and he writes
closer to what we might call real books
and he's so busy being an adult that he
only hosts a weekly show on Fox News
because he's really serious and so when
you sit down with Mark Levin and you've
got the dark lighting as you can see if
you're watching everything about it is
this is a serious interview with a
serious person and if you're so serious
that you can be interviewed by Mark
Levin you must also be a very serious
person it's all a joke it's all it's all
just complete and total nonsense and
Mark Levin is a bomb thrower partisan
bomb thrower just like everybody else
spreads this information it's just a
story that they make up but understand
that's the context Ron DeSantis is a
very important deep thinker and so he's
going to come in and have a serious
conversation with Mark Levin starting
with talking about the woke and again
the framing here is they interviewed
DeSantis as if he's already running for
national office he's the governor of
Florida don't forget he's the governor
of Florida but the context and the
framing and the questions and the topics
are this is a guy who should be on the
national stage and has a lot to say
about National politics starting with
talking about the woke yes you do have
to fight the woke in the halls of
government and in legislative Chambers
right and we have super majorities as
Republicans of Florida so we will win
all those fights but you also have to be
willing to defend your folks against
this agenda being shoved down their
throat from all these other institutions
terrible or these people aren't
necessarily coming up for election so
you talk about things with like the
young kids and with Disney
listen this guy is at the Forefront of
the most important issues the woke have
to be fought in the halls of government
and I mean look at the this major issue
of Disney Disney affirmed in some
nominal way
gay rights and so we've got to deal with
the woke folks but understand this is
what Republicans want to hear they want
to hear a lot of the same
pseudo-fascistic so-called culture War
issues presented in a marginally more
serious manner than Trump presents them
now that's a separate issue from whether
if a campaign gets going
constitutionally personality wise
DeSantis has what it takes to face Trump
the different question but this is the
same old nonsense he then talks about
how there was an attempt to impose
intersectionality oh the horror the
horror Florida our standards require
teaching all aspects of black history
and we think it's important we also when
we ban critical race Theory which we
were right to do well right or wrong it
was nonsense uh we also required in that
same bill that schools have stories of
inspiration about out great Floridians
and great Americans from a variety of
different backgrounds I want students we
need an entire thing about Dana White
and the heroic UFC events he held during
the virus pandemic right to to be to be
inspired that they can do well in
Florida you know as they get all
critical race theory is basically saying
summer oppressor some are oppressed what
kind of a message is that sending to
these very young kids so so we require
all of that and remember there was no
critical race Theory being taught to
young kids our standards in terms of the
basic history with the College Board was
trying to do they were trying to impose
CRT they actually were trying to impose
in a black studies course queer Theory
they were trying to impose
intersectionality and they were trying
to impose effectively neo-marxism and so
the question is is that something you
want to do on your own time yeah yeah
you're free save neo-marxism for the
privacy of your bedroom please
Sue that but for our taxpayers to be
supporting that type of indoctrination
that is not something that we want to do
now you might be hearing this and saying
David what the hell is Ron DeSantis
talking about here well he's talking
about the things that potential 2024
voters want to hear him talk about it's
the Glenn yunkin sort of routine run on
these things talk about these things all
the time which aren't really issues and
aren't actually happening the topic came
up of uh the Electoral College and the
Mandate and power that that winning the
Electoral College gives to a president
that's very interesting because you know
a lot of these small government supposed
small government conservatives talk
about you know we we actually should
take Powers away from the executive we
are they'll just say whatever they think
they need to say yeah it's hard to
remove them you know the Civil Service
rules and then the union oh and sorry
and this relates to the idea that they
bemoan they would like it to be easier
to fire government employees that's the
context here rules and all the rest and
well there was one there was a proposal
uh that I think a lot of us wanted to
see under the prior Administration to to
do the prior Administration
who what was that guy's name schedule F
so anybody that has any policy role is
classified as a schedule F and they can
be removed uh by the president the left
would litigate that but I honestly think
we would win on that in the Supreme
Court and I also isn't this a great
serious interview guys I think it's one
thing to have some type of job rules for
the the bowels of the bureaucracy like
your supervisor what they can do
president United States has Article 2
power who controls the executive branch
right is it the elected president or is
it some bureaucrat in the bowels of the
bureaucracy that can't be a lot of focus
on bowels in this interview he fired and
so I think push needs to come to shove
on this but whoever gets a majority of
the Electoral College is has the right
to impose their agenda through the
executive branch right and what they did
with President Trump was basically try
to nullify the election through not only
bureaucratic intransigence but
malfeasance with the collusion hoax and
some of those things well really really
throwing in everything there so listen
what they're talking about here is that
they're you know the federal government
is a major employer and there are all
sorts of of jobs and roles within the
federal government there are some which
truly are
only uh bureaucratic positions they are
not in any way remotely political and
then there are jobs within an
Administration and federal government
that are obviously political the
president's cabinet for example and Well
on down from there and the idea was
Trump and some Republicans have gotten
the idea that in the middle there's a
ton of nominally bureaucratic positions
that are actually very political
and so rather than having those jobs be
protected by unions and and a mediation
and arbitration all these different
things they just want to make the
president be able to fire all of these
people and these are huge numbers of
roles and of course if you have the view
that these really aren't political
positions and these are jobs that people
depend on in a way that a secretary of
state is not likely to depend on that
job to feed their family that they
should be protected from a president
coming in and just going replace
everybody not to mention in a lot of
these jobs you really don't want to be
replacing people every few years is is
the truth so this is what they're
talking about making it easier to fire
people so again a completely deranged
interview
authoritarian while still pretending
that he's kind of small government
framed as a very serious discussion
between legal Scholars when it's
actually just the same tired political
nonsense with a little bit of different
window dressing and quite frankly if Ron
DeSantis decides to run for president
that I think is what the the candidacy
will be the same old political nonsense
and supposed culture War issues as a
shield for authoritarianism with
slightly different window dressing all
of these clips that I've played for you
here will have them on our YouTube
channel at youtube.com the davidpackman
show but also on the Spanish YouTube
channel
what was that something is glitching
start do you guys hear that oh my God I
gotta get out of here dear God oh my
goodness okay let's close everything
geez that was really embarrassing the
Spanish Channel
davidpackman.com Spanish approaching 2
000 subscribers let's take a break fix
all the technical problems and come
right back
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
no matter what other people tell you
remember that the David packman show is
funded directly by our viewers it's not
the DNC the way a very respectful person
left a voicemail for me this morning
claiming it's not George Soros or any of
the stuff that you sometimes hear uh
repeated in the comments of my YouTube
channel we're mostly funded by our
viewers and listeners and you can sign
up and become one of those supporters at
joinpakman.com I don't even care if you
use the huge discount code 24 starts now
we just want people involved at any
level that works for you you'll get the
daily bonus show the commercial free
audio and video streams of the show
invitations to the members only town
halls and we now have a sound board for
our members just like my soundboard
where I play my stuff here thank your
lucky stars every day you're not Dave
Pacman exactly you have access to the
very same sound board that I have here
you can sign up at joinpakman.com it's
quick it's easy and it is a beautiful
thing
former democratic congresswoman Tulsi
gabbard who now regularly speaks at
anti-vaccine events
seemed to shock even Fox News host Jesse
Waters when she compared affirmative
action ideas and the idea of
um I mean I don't even she compared
Biden to Hitler I don't even know how
else to say it this you have to see the
general subject matter during the former
congresswoman's interview with Jesse
Waters was Biden quote choosing
diversity over competence which by the
way there's no evidence at all that Joe
Biden has done
um and she said these are the principles
that the Nazis and Hitler embodied she
has really taken well to this new role
as an anti-woke free speech whatever
they call her at this point right their
philosophy identity politics and this is
one of the main reasons why I left the
Democratic by the way I'm sorry it
already interrupt I wonder remember tool
sees against identity politics will she
come out against the identity politics
campaign of Nikki Haley who's like I
don't really know of any reason that you
would vote for me over Trump on policy
but like I'm younger and a woman and of
Indian Heritage is she is is too because
Tulsi of course would never play
partisan games okay sorry let's take it
from the top here their philosophy
identity politics and this is one of the
main reasons why I left the Democratic
party because you're seeing how their
agenda of identity politics is directly
undermining the traditional democratic
values that were expressed so
beautifully and clearly by Dr Martin
Luther King that we should judge each
other not based on the color of our skin
but based on our character and yet as
you have displayed here over and over at
the example after example they're proud
to be judging people hiring people
selecting People based on race which is
really let's be clear how serious of a
problem this is yeah it's based on
genetics race uh based on your blood
your genes and and where do we see that
connection well these are the very same
geneticist core principles embodied by
Nazism and Adolf Hitler and this should
be something that is sickening and
alarming to every single Democrat and
everything it's sickening and alarming
to me that Tulsi would say this single
American we have seen where this uh
philosophy can lead right
noticing hey we dramatically
underrepresent for example black women
in the Judiciary maybe we could like
make them slightly less
underrepresentative next thing you know
they'll be coming to kill the Jews it's
exactly the thing this is insane now let
you all know me on this issue I don't
believe that we can even remotely have a
Judiciary that exactly matches the
American population along every
demographic line I have not heard anyone
on the left say listen
um the population is like 50.5 percent
women so 50.5 percent of all judges
should be women and white people make up
what is it now like 69 of the population
so we need 69 of the population of the
Judiciary to be white and then 12 of the
population is 55 to 64. I'm making that
number up now so 12 of the Judiciary
must be 55 to 60. nobody that I have
seen
myself included is calling for that type
of equality of outcome when it comes to
the Judiciary
what Joe Biden has identified is that
the Judiciary is already dramatically
unrepresentative of the population at
Large
so Joe Biden during his tenure so far
has nominated
disproportionately more black women to
the Judiciary that's true
and we still have a dramatic
underrepresentation of black women in
the Judiciary Joe Biden has only made it
slightly more reflective of the
population now what the right loves to
say is because of the prioritization of
identity over competency by virtue of
appointing a lot of black a lot
comparatively more black women
we are reducing the competency because
they're being chosen not for their
judicial Acumen but instead because of
their racial identity this is one of the
dumbest things that they claim when they
want to act against identity
act against affirmative so-called
affirmative action under the guise of
identity politics this is a country of
331 million people
my guess is if you said we are going to
have a Judiciary that is 70 black women
there are enough competent black women
judges that you could do it and they
would all be competent similarly if you
said we're going to have 80 percent of
the Judiciary be Asian people oh but
isn't that going to choose racial
identity over competency we have 331
million people in this country and we
have enough competent Asian jurists that
you could do that anyway so the issue is
not that we are choosing incompetent
people based only on their race it's we
have so many competent people of all
Races in this country that if you say
well I'm going to over select a group
that has been historically under
selected you're choosing from all
competent people that's the reality and
there doesn't sound anything like Nazism
in it to me if you disagree with me let
me know
Fox News host Howard Kurtz admits he's
not talking about the Dominion lawsuit
against Fox News because Fox News told
him you're not allowed to talk about
this now a lot of people are making a
very very big deal out of this I'm going
to give you my view of it in a moment
Howard Kurtz does like the media
Watchdog show on Fox News the show is
pretty bad but the point here is he
brings this up Dominion is suing Fox
News over their role in promoting
conspiracy theories about Dominion
voting machines in the aftermath of the
2020 election Howard Kurtz and others on
Fox News haven't talked about it why
Howard Kurtz explains some of you have
been you've been asking why I'm not
covering the Dominion voting machines
lawsuit against Fox involving the
unproven claims of election fraud in
2020 and it's absolutely a fair question
yes I believe I should be covering it
it's a major media story given my role
here at Fox but the company has decided
that as part of the organization being
sued I can't talk about it or write
about it at least for now I strongly
disagree with that decision but as an
employee I have to abide by it and if
that changes I'll let you know yeah so
many of you have pointed out to me that
Fox News is completely silent about the
fact that there is this massive lawsuit
and the discovery led to the revelation
of those texts wherein we learned that
Fox News hosts who on air were
pretending like there was Merit to the
things being said by Donald Trump about
the 2020 election we're texting each
other and admitting it's all lies it's
all crazy there's nothing here it's a
major story and Fox News hasn't been
talking about it now I I have to tell
you this is not the big shocker that
some are making it out to be there is no
doubt about the newsworthiness of the
subject matter and I'll tell you what I
think no matter what Fox News hosts
wouldn't be allowed to talk about it but
it is true
that any lawyer worth anything would
tell Fox News don't talk about this
lawsuit on the air because it can only
create more problems for you best case
scenario it doesn't help you but it
doesn't hurt you worst case scenario you
do what Alex Jones was doing daily on
his program while the defamation suit
against him was going on and you just
damage yourself so
I think no matter what like aside from
lawyers making the suggestion Fox News
has probably determined this isn't a
good thing for us to be talking about
regardless but there is no way that
lawyers aren't for Fox News aren't
saying do not talk about the lawsuit on
the air so the most you could say about
you know someone like Howard Kurtz is if
you really disagree with it that much
then you should leave
that's perfectly fair thing to say
at the same time it's expected CNN would
do the same thing MSNBC would do the
same thing in this situation it would be
quite silly to be talking about the
lawsuit Alex Jones did it and we saw how
well that went for him uh we have yet
another data point
in which we find that while claiming
that the left was censoring the right on
Twitter and elsewhere the Trump
Administration was demanding others be
censored so let let me back up a little
bit as we start to talk about this story
during the first I guess the first
couple days of hearings about
the weaponization of big Tech or
whatever it was we learned we learned
that the Trump Administration wanted
celebrity Chrissy Teigen
um uh censored for an insult she made
about President Donald Trump let me
remind you we this remember these were
hearings meant to make the left look bad
and they made the right look like
triggered snowflakes
um Miss uh uh niravoli earlier you
testified about a 2019 tweet yeah um
that was about President Trump and I
think it's from Miss Teagan what was the
Tweet about yeah
would you like me to give the direct
quote yeah
um please excuse my language this is a
direct quote but Chrissy Teigen referred
to Donald Trump as a ass
okay
free speech and what happened after Miss
Teagan posted her tweet what did the
White House do what did the Trump White
House do right from my understanding the
White House reached out to ask that this
tweet be removed it was my team's uh job
uh this fell underneath the policy for
abusive behaviors and we evaluate it
underneath our insults policy at that
time up to three insults were allowed
and so it was our job to determine how
many insults were included within that
phrase White House reached out not an
agency but the White House reached out
and requested that you remove the the
tweet from my understanding yes okay so
the story that they were telling on the
right is it's the left that constantly
wants to do censorship and blah blah
blah blah blah a celebrity insults Trump
and they try to get the Tweet deleted
but we now know that that's not the only
such example we have also now learned uh
that the Trump White House was
pressuring Disney meaning ABC to censor
Jimmy Kimmel this is uh
at this point are we surprised by this
at all Rolling Stone article the former
president was so incensed by the late
night host Jimmy Kimmel making fun of
him that he had his staff take action
this was in early 2018
um The American National Security
apparatus was fixated on reports that
North Korea was building nuclear weapons
which could reach the U.S or that Russia
was plotting chemical weapons
assassinations in Europe Trump meanwhile
was busy targeting his idea of An Enemy
of the State late night host Jimmy
Kimmel according to two former Trump
Administration officials Trump was so
upset by Jimmy Kimmel's comedic Jabs
that he directed White House staff to
call up one of Disney's top Executives
in DC to complain and demand action ABC
is owned by Disney in at least two
separate phone calls that occurred
around the time Trump was finishing his
first year in office the White House
conveyed the severity of Trump's Fury
with Kimmel to Disney Trump's staff
mentioned the leader of the Free World
wanted the bill billion dollar company
to reign in Jimmy Kimmel for trashing
Trump and Trump felt that Kimmel had in
the characterization of a former
Administration official been very
dishonest and doing things that Trump
would have sued over
the incident was so bizarre news of it
spread around the corridors of power in
DC other Administration officials who
had nothing to do with the pressure
campaign expressed they were confused
that the white that they expressed
hearing from Disney that they were
confused that the White House was
telling them Trump wants to tone down
the humor they
are the triggered snowflakes and I know
we've said it so many times before
accusations or confessions and it's
projection and all these different
things
it really is the truth and from the
Twitter files we learned basically that
the Trump administration had the same
access if that's what you want to call
it to request things be removed as the
Biden campaign remember Trump
Administration Biden campaign and from
all of these anecdotes we're learning
that the Trump White House was regularly
trying to use their powers of censorship
while claiming that it is the left that
was trying to censor them it is yet
another case where the truth is the
opposite of what they tell us I am sure
these two examples that we mentioned
today aren't the only ones
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show let's talk
a little more about this loyalty pledge
that Republicans and the Republican
National Committee want every candidate
who is vying for the Republican primary
to sign in advance of participating in
any debates we talked about this last
week many of you wrote to me about it
and we have more about it I'll remind
you what's going on the RNC and the
Republican Party want every single
candidate who's running to agree in
advance even if I lose I will support
whoever is event actually the Republican
nominee really the concern here is Trump
why well Trump is a child and Trump puts
himself above everything above party
above everything and so it's a
legitimate risk to the Republican party
that Trump might run in the Republican
primary but lose maybe DeSantis wins
maybe who knows somebody else wins and
then Trump instead of saying hey you
know what I lost Farin Square I'm going
to support the person that won I mean
it's like laughable that he would do
that right
Trump instead will say well you know
what it was stolen it was rigged and I'm
going to run as an independent and show
these Republicans whose boss and the
reason that this would be so devastating
to the party is there are so many states
where the margins are always thin
whether it's a Republican or a Democrat
who wins everything from Florida
Pennsylvania Ohio Michigan Wisconsin
Arizona there's so many states where
it's always pretty close
if Trump ran as an independent and took
just five to seven percent of the
Republican vote it would guarantee that
the Democratic candidate wins Trump
running as an independent could
guarantee one of the biggest Democratic
victories in 2024 that we've seen in
decades so they've asked him to sign a
loyalty pledge they're asking everybody
to sign a loyalty pledge and one of the
things that came up last week was Trump
isn't going to do this but now there's a
different perspective now the
perspective for many of you is oh Trump
will do it he just won't abide by it
well on CNN Ronald McDaniel was asked by
Dana Bash about this entire loyalty
pledge scenario and here's what she had
to say I want you to listen to what
former president Donald Trump said a
couple of weeks ago in an interview with
uh conservative radio host Hugh Hewitt
on this very topic please
if you're not the nominee will you
support whoever the GOP nominee is it
would depend I would I would give you
the same answer I gave in 2016 during
the debate it would have to depend on
who the nominee was
so are you prepared to block the former
president in 2016. I did everybody
signed it in 2016. but this is about the
here and the now he didn't commit to it
I think they're all going to sign it I
really do I think the voters are very
intent on winning and they do not want
to see a debate stage of people saying
I'm not going to support this guy I'm
not going to support this guy what they
need to say is I'm going to do
everything I can to defeat Joe Biden and
that means supporting the nominee of the
Republican party you can't see a
scenario where Donald Trump would just
skip the debate if he's forced to sign
something I want to be on the debate
stage I think president Trump would like
to be on the debate stage that's what he
likes to do and I expect they'll all be
there so listen
I actually have revised my view a little
bit last week I was really leaning
towards Trump's never going to sign this
thing and they will capitulate and let
them on the stage because otherwise
their voters will you know start a
mutiny I actually now believe the more
likely scenario is Trump will sign
whatever he needs to sign to get to the
debate stage he'll play Coy if and when
the question comes up during the debates
but then if he loses he'll say screw
that pledge it's not legally binding it
means nothing I signed it but then when
I signed it I I meant if they if they
fairly win they didn't fairly defeat me
so I'm going to go and run as an
independent anyway if that's what he
wants to do the point is Trump's
completely dishonest in this way
and the more I think about it I can't
think of any
anyone who knows Trump at all the way we
do because we've been following him for
so long who thinks he would actually
come out and just say I am going to
support this person that just defeated
me it's very difficult to imagine that
that's the case the interview had
another interesting moment uh which was
about accepting the results of 2024 and
Ronald McDaniel also plays koi with this
she goes oh yeah no I think all the
candidates will accept the 2024 results
because we're going to win which is
exactly the language that got us into
the 2020 mess to begin with Thomas we
were talking about promises now that
whomever the Republican nominee is yeah
ultimately will accept the results in
2024. I expect that they will accept the
results in 2024. I I'm not I don't know
who that person is right now but yes
we're gonna accept the results
um and we're going to move forward and
work to to govern this country but I
think they're going to accept the
results because they're going to be the
president
well that doesn't really Inspire
confidence Ron saying they will accept
it either way is different than there's
going to be no reason not to accept it
because the Republican can that it will
have won so listen it's not a big
surprise but they are already gearing up
for the same election denying nonsense
in 2024 let's not get ahead of ourselves
on that there's time to get to that but
just know they are setting it up it is
still really unclear to me but also to
Nikki Haley why anyone should vote for
her according to Nikki Haley we talked
last week about how Nikki Haley was
asked like why would people vote for you
and it was basically like I don't really
know and identity politics well I'm a
different generation and you know women
power and I'm also a minority and just
very strange stuff to hear from
Republicans who claim to be against
identity politics she's now had another
week to try to come up with some policy
ideas she was asked about her record at
the U.N
she could name nothing other than that
she did a book
she didn't write a book she did a book
are these do these count as answers in
politics at this point or in Republican
politics we've been talking about
foreign policy this morning you did an
incredible job at the UN fighting for
America First how do you differentiate
yourself from the other candidates and
remember the other candidates Trump
right I mean that's it's Trump and Vivek
ramaswamy who who's whose announcement
went over like a lead balloon it's your
plan for foreign give us the plan
well you know one of the main things I
did at the United Nations that I think
is so important is I did a book that
focused on the 193 company countries the
193 companies in the oh my god let's
we've got to run that back the this this
is an answer she was asked what would
you do in terms of foreign policy
you know one of the main things I did at
the United states that I think is
did a book that focused on the 193
company countries the percentage of time
they voted with us and how much foreign
aid we give them yeah uh Chef can you
tell us what would be your approach to
uh poultry based dishes if you were to
be hired to run this restaurant listen
one of the biggest things I did over the
last three months is I did a book where
I would list items available at
different restaurants
oh oh okay but so like what would what
would the poultry dishes be here it's
just completely incoherent and by the
way she did a book containing
information anyone can just Google about
different countries and by the way it's
not even clear she actually claims to
have written it notice that she said she
did a book rather than I wrote a book
this is really a problem in my eyes I
don't know the Republican voters care
about policy but she continues to do
this remember last week she was asked
you know what like why would anyone vote
for you and just very confusing answers
okay so I want to put up something from
the Wall Street Journal this week they
said you had a a great day your great
rollout day but they said you have to
provide a rationale for your candidacy
that you haven't done yet they said
you've got to answer this question about
why you versus anybody else in the in
the GOP field you know they're talking
about the fact that you say you know
America First America should be powerful
those are things that any GOP candidate
is going to say so why you
why not me you know I am a the wife of a
combat veteran I'm a mother of two
children one who's getting married and I
see how hard it is for her to look at
buying a home one that's in college and
I see what he's dealing with with woke
education you know I'm the daughter of
immigrant parents who are upset by
what's happening at the border I don't
want to wait for someone else to fix
this anyway so her as you might remember
her answer was basically
um you know there's there's people not
enjoying what they're being taught and
woke and you know I'm the daughter of
immigrants truly a horrendous candidate
I mean just horrifyingly bad and usually
candidates are able to cite reasons to
vote for them which we might say that's
not a good reason she's not even able to
cite what would count as a reason now if
we want to take a very quick look at the
latest polling
um you know it it's not as bad as I
thought for Nikki Haley if we look at
the most recent a rated poll which is a
Fox News poll remember Fox News polling
actually isn't bad it's conducted by
Beacon research they have a poll if it's
Trump head to head against Haley Trump
crushes Haley 66-24 and that's not super
shocking if it's a multi-way poll it's
Trump 43 followed by DeSantis 28 and
then Nikki Haley tied for third with
seven percent seven percent nothing to
sneeze at given that she just launched
her campaign a couple weeks ago
um it's not great and by the way if I
was a betting man I'm not my bet is
Nikki Haley does not end up getting
seven percent of the vote in the
Republican primary but it's not even
March of 2023 yet so so you know who
knows but uh listen I mean she's
starting with seven all right that's
something you can build from at least
hypothetically I don't know that you're
gonna build it by having no policy and
just saying you're younger than Trump a
woman and and of Indian Heritage I'm not
sure that that gets you beyond seven
percent
but it will be interesting to watch
we'll take a very quick break I am going
to talk about the Scott Adams racist
meltdown uh I have a history with Scott
Adams we'll talk about that and other
things after this very short break
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
all right let's talk about the Dilbert
Scott Adams Fiasco uh so some of you may
recall that Scott Adams the guy who
draws the Dilbert cartoon has been on
this program before and we used to kind
of mix it up on Twitter and then a few
years ago I think it was kind of
earliest in the pandemic he just blocked
me on Twitter and I know that I could
like log out to see what he's posting
but I don't care that much so I've not
been following Scott Adams since he cut
me off and when he would be on we would
have like spirited discussions which I
thought were generally pretty good but
something kind of started to go wrong
with Scott Adams and when he banned me a
black band me when he blocked me from
Twitter
he really seemed to almost like crack
like it was I don't remember what it was
over but he I think I said oh I think
that you're arguing in bad faith about
something and he went crazy insulted me
and then blocked me and and just seems
to kind of descend it into a dark place
over the last several years
I found out over the weekend that he
Unleashed a completely racist meltdown
style tirade on Twitter and that this
subsequently led to a bunch of
newspapers saying yeah we're gonna get
rid of Dilbert we're all set with
Dilbert we're not going to have it
anymore now I I admit personally it
really bums me out I used to love
Dilbert growing up and I know a lot of
people like oh Dilbert's so lame it's
boring whatever I really liked it
growing up and it was just kind of a sad
thing
to see Scott Adams descend into such
political insanity and now even beyond
that where I don't know this seems to be
going beyond the political to the
personal something really seems to be
going on but fear not he has some
Defenders Elon Musk has come out of the
woodwork to defend Scott Adams so let's
look at what's going on CNN article from
this morning says Elon Musk defended
Dilbert Creator Scott Adams after
hundreds of newspapers stopped printing
the comic strip because of Adam's recent
racist comments last week Adams called
Black Americans a hate group and
suggested white people should quote get
the hell away from them oof Adams
effectively encouraged segregation in a
shocking rant on his YouTube channel his
comments came in response to a poll from
the conservative firm Rasmussen reports
not a good pollster by the way that said
53 percent of black Americans agree with
the statement it's okay to be white
in response to a tweet twitter owner
musk said Sunday that quote the media is
racist
you know it's so funny the Wright loves
to say
you got to be really careful when you
call someone racist that's one of the
most serious things you can do how can
you call Scott Adams racist when you
don't know what's in his head and
regardless of what he said he might not
really be racist in all these things oh
oh Elon Musk is defending him the media
is racist yep check us out no no
critique needed there
um musk also didn't criticize Scott
Adams comments and musk said without
evidence that quote for a very long time
the U.S media was racist against
non-white people now they're racist
against whites and Asians
same thing happened with Elite colleges
and high schools in America maybe they
can try not being racist musk later
agreed with a tweet saying Adam's
comments weren't good but had an element
of Truth
he accused the media of giving black
victims of police violence
disproportionate coverage over white
black people are more likely to die from
Police use of force than white people
according to multiple studies
what were Adam's comments well here they
are
um he said on his YouTube show quote if
nearly half of all blacks are not okay
with white people according to this poll
not according to me that's a hate group
I don't want to have anything to do with
them and I would say based on the
current way things are going the best
advice I would give to white people is
to get the hell away from black people
just get the F away because there's no
fixing this he has since said on Twitter
he was only advising people to avoid
hate so anyway we now have all these
articles about how newspapers are
dropping the comic strip and of course
all of these right-wingers are saying
this is now censorship
some newspapers said it's not a
difficult decision the Cleveland Plains
dealer said we are dropping the Dilbert
comic strip because of Scott Adams
racist Rand USA today's Network also
dropped it so listen it's all the exact
same stuff that we always hear and it's
the same routine Scott Adams in response
to this tweeted quote Dilbert has been
canceled from all new newspapers
websites calendars and books because I
gave some advice everyone agreed with
wow my syndication partner canceled me
so listen I think something is is very I
think Scott Adams is struggling
personally but that doesn't mean we
excuse the things he said everybody here
is exercising their rights Scott Adams
expressed his speech in this insane
tirade on YouTube which he followed up
on Twitter
people who read it responded and said I
either like that or I don't and some of
them stopped following Scott Adams and
some of them said I'm not going to read
the Dilbert strip anymore and some of
them wrote to newspapers and said don't
carry this anymore everybody is speaking
this is speech and then newspapers made
a decision with whatever barometer they
want to use to make that decision some
said we're no longer going to carry the
comic strip everybody is expressing
their rights it's the free market at
work it's action and reaction remember
we're not talking about the First
Amendment because this is not about the
government doing anything but we are
talking here about everybody's rights to
say what they want and sometimes things
you say have consequences a lot of
people struggle or are unwilling to
accept
that quote free speech sometimes used
colloquially doesn't mean my speech
can't have consequences or therefore it
is no longer free speech and of course
good thing Elon Musk showed up and
cleared it up by reminding us the media
is racist which really added significant
moral clarity as you can imagine so
let's
everybody here has been allowed to say
whatever they want you don't have a
right to have a syndicated
um comic strip if Scott Adams wants to
take control back he can keep drawing
Dilbert and just release it on his
website he would then control the
platform nobody would be able to quote
cancel him and that's absolutely
something that he can do but it's
seeming like a sort of sad
I don't want to call it the end for
Scott Adams but it's been a very sad
decline particularly for me because I
really used to like the comic script
when I was you know 12 years old I I
thought it was good Mitt Romney is
blasting Marjorie Taylor green on her
secession Insanity we're going to look
at a short clip remember that Marjorie
Taylor green last week said that we need
a national divorce where we divide up
into red States and blue States I told
you all of the reasons why that makes no
sense uh Senator Mitt Romney a
republican was asked about it and here's
what he had to say senator what do you
think about representative Marjorie
Taylor Green's call on social media
media for a national divorce dividing
the country up between Republican and
Democratic states you know I think
Abraham Lincoln dealt with that kind of
uh Insanity we're not going to divide
the country it's uh united we stand
divided we fall yeah listen I didn't
vote for Mitt Romney but he does seem
like a fundamentally decent and honest
guy who just tells you what he thinks
and he thinks a lot of Modern
Republicanism is completely insane now
I've told you the two main reasons why
this entire separate into two countries
won't work the first is the
unconstitutionality of unilateral
secession now baby maybe Marjorie Taylor
green is talking about a version where
like everybody agrees everybody's like
no yeah yeah like Oklahoma you should go
go do your own thing but the
Constitution of the United States which
is the supreme law of the land doesn't
provide a provision for secession and in
fact the idea of secession arguably was
tested in the Civil War
Supreme Court has ruled you can't just
secede States can't just say we succeed
it's not a legal option for any state if
you attempt to do it you would be
violating the Constitution and Supreme
Court rulings now the second part of it
is that the red States aren't viable as
a country and I know that if you watched
last week's show you already know this
but I do want to get it into this clip
as well the red State country that would
be created is fundamentally not viable
economically and this is for a number of
different reasons GDP per capita is much
lower in red States than blue states red
states are disproportionately subsidized
with Federal funding that comes from
Blue states which overwhelmingly pay
money in rather than get money out blue
States on average have more diverse
economies whereas red states often
depend on one industry or product or
sector
so it's very at risk to that one you
know oil in Texas or agriculture in
Kansas so that makes the economies
generally more vulnerable to economic
fluctuations there are on average more
educated people in the blue states that
leads to higher paying jobs and more
Innovation there's better infrastructure
as a result in the blue States
education and access to health care tend
to be better which also makes it more
attractive for business it's a vicious
cycle and right now to a great degree
the red states are being pulled up by
all of these aspects of blue States if
you've just got red States as a country
it really wouldn't work well at all and
Mitt Romney just pointing out that it
makes no sense for a number of reasons
good for Mitt Romney
I wish there were more Republicans
willing to stand up and just say these
these people shouldn't be here Marjorie
Taylor green is a disaster Mitt Romney
went up to George Santos George Anthony
devalder Santos during the state of the
union and said I'm shocked you're even
here you should be ashamed
um if we had more Republicans like Mitt
Romney the Republican Party would be
just a party with we disagree with on
policy and less of the scourge or
scourge
on the United States that it has become
we have a voicemail number the number is
2192 David P I made a mistake last week
and I apologize for it
I'll remind you what the mistake was and
it relates to Charlie and the Chocolate
Factory
not a Justice glue Augustus Gloop
um he is so fat that he gets stuck in
the whatever
tubing system is carrying the chocolate
outside
but it was Violet Beauregard he swelled
to the blue to the size of a blueberry
and turned blue yeah so last week we
were talking on the bonus show that you
know the bonus show I hope oh the bonus
show where you want to make money yes
everybody else it makes money to find
themselves as bad we were talking about
the effort to rewrite elements of Roald
Dahl's books including Willy Wonka uh
the Willy Wonka's chocolate factory
Charlie and the Chocolate Factory will I
forget that with the book and movie have
a different name in any case one of the
things is they don't like Augustus Gloop
being described as enormously fat
anymore that's I guess wrong so
Publishers want to change it to
something else and I was describing you
know he's like he swells like a
blueberry but that is not the story it
is indeed Violet that swells like a
blueberry an Augustus Gloop is the one
who gets like stuck in the piping I
guess of the Chocolate Factory I was
wrong about what I said my analysis is
the same which I am against the
rewriting of books I think the book is a
complete Act
it is not to be now retrospectively
modified yes Roald Dahl was a horrible
anti-semite that's a separate issue
from whether we should mess with the
vocabulary in the book
uh and we had an extensive conversation
about this with Pat on the bonus show
which I welcome you to check out but I
was wrong in my retelling of the story
and I apologize we have a great bonus
show for you today Democrats have seen a
major shift and now prefer Joe Biden as
the nominee interesting an Idaho bill
would criminalize giving mRNA vaccines
what why
you can probably guess and the Pentagon
is warning that poppy seed Bagels could
be a threat to National Security yes it
is related to the Seinfeld episode about
the poppy seed Bagel so we will talk
about all of those stories and more on
today's bonus show please do yourselves
a favor sign up at joinpakman.com before
they take your machines we're doing a
class action lawsuit against all
machines before they take your phone and
your espresso machine and your desktop
computer and all of it get a membership
at joinpachman.com I'll see you on the
bonus show
foreign